hi I'm Tessa King and these are my  beauty hats on when to save and when to  splurge on your beauty products so one  of my favorite ways to save money is  making beauty products at home now I  take anything from the kitchen and I  make natural hair masks and body scrubs  spend a bit more money and invest in  your workout gear and a good pair of  trainers it will make you feel amazing  and it will keep you motivated save time  and money by doing your hair removal  treatments at home with the Phillips  Lumiere you get the same amazing results  as you do at a salon like my visit pure  three-in-one a lot of my products on  multi-use I've used my lip gloss  as a highlighter and my bronzer for a  nice warm eyeshadow thank you so much  for watching  those are my beauty hacks for saving or  splurging  you  [Music]